muslims at prayers
it's a scene most germans know only from
television
this is where salim worships he's 19
studies technology
and identifies strongly with his faith
he says he's involved with the young
people's islam conference
to show that being a german citizen and
a practicing muslim
can go hand in hand
everyone has their own view those
different perspectives need to be
brought together because everyone's
personal view will necessarily be
limited
contact and communication those are the
issues which attracted 20 year old
violetta to the conference
she's a social sciences student from
berlin
diversity in german society has become
normal for so many people in schools or
kindergartens for example
but there are a lot of places like
public offices local government and
large organizations where there is still
no visible diversity
a recent survey carried out by a berlin
university
shows the difference between generations
in germany when it comes to contact with
islam
only eight percent of young adults said
they had never had any contact with
muslims
among the over 25s that number rises to
22
on contentious issues the generational
disconnect was even bigger
70 percent of young adults opposed the
ban of teachers wearing the hijab
only around half of over 25s were
opposed
we can see that the germany of the
future will be much more pragmatic about
this issue
diversity is much more a part of
everyday life already for young people
so i think the attitudes highlighted by
this study are a reason for optimism
praying at the mosque is a daily ritual
for salim
he says he wants to make islam a normal
part of a diverse german society
and not just on television